What if you asked people in AI: What if
you were right? What if you actually
succeeded in the goals that you have set
for the field? And it seemed to me that
almost no one was asking that question,
and certainly nobody had an answer. And
over the—that was in the early 90s—
and over the next 20 years or so I
started to think about what kinds of
answers you might have. And it became, I
would say, a little bit more urgent for
me when I saw Big Dog which is the
Boston Dynamics, the four-legged robot,
which you see in that video where the
one of their engineers tries to push it
over
basically kicks this robot, tries to
push it to the ground with his foot. So
he's probably the first to go. And, you
know, and I, and it actually, you know, it
sort of recoils and stumbles, and
gets back on its feet again in such a
lifelike way. And I had worked on leg
locomotion in the 90s and it's a hard
problem. And you look at that video you
think, "Okay, that problem is basically
solved." What if we solved some of
the other problems? The problems of
dexterous manipulation for robots, which
is another big open problem in the field.
The problem of understanding language.
What if we actually nail these
problems? And to some extent we've
now largely nailed the problem of speech
recognition. And in some ways, although in very fragile and peculiar ways, we've solved
the problem of recognition of objects in
visual images. And if you've ever used
Google Translate these days, machine
translation seems to work incredibly
well. So we're starting to nail some of
these problems. And so this has made me
think harder. And here's the problem that
I see: We have what you might call the
standard model. So physics has its
standard model and AI has a standard
model. And it's the same standard model
that control theory has, that cybernetics
has, that statistics has, that economics
has, operations research—it's the same
model: You create optimizing machinery
for which you specify an objective, and
then you hope that you've got the
objective right. And so interestingly, so
John [Brockman] was talking about the book by
Norbert Wiener, The Human Use of Human Beings
and in that book he says, "The purpose
that we put into the machine has to be
the purpose that we really desire
otherwise we're toast." So that's the
standard model; this is how we do things.
So this is, you know, a big chunk of 20th
century technology is based on that
model. And Wiener also said that it's
only human impotence that has protected us from human folly.
By which he meant that our machines are
so stupid, and they have impacts on such
a small scale but if you put the wrong
purpose in, up to now you've been able to
switch them off, reset, you know, hit
yourself on the head say, "Okay,
obviously I forgot, you know, I forgot
about this, I forgot about that. So the
question is: When machines are more
intelligent than human beings, we may not
have that choice.
DAVE: "Open the pod bay doors, Hal."
HAL 9000: "I'm sorry Dave, I'm afraid I can't do
that."
And even before that. So we talked
about social media. So Rod (Brooks) was
saying that we are sort of at the mercy
of social media. But look at this
from the point of view of the machine.
What is the purpose put into the
machine?
The purpose is: maximize click-through,
right? Feed people stuff that they're
going to click on, because that's how we
make money, right? And you might say well,
how do you maximize click-through? You
just send people stuff that they like
clicking on, right? Simple as that.
Actually, that's not what the algorithms
are doing. That's probably what Facebook
and Google and so on thought that the
algorithms were going to do—that the
algorithms would adjust to the people's
preferences. But in fact, that's not how
reinforcement learning works.
Reinforcement learning changes the state
of the world to maximize the reward. And
the state of the world in this case is
your brain. So what does it do? It changes
you in a way that makes you more
predictable, so that it can then send you
stuff that it knows you're going to
click on. And who is more predictable
than a raving fascist or a raving
communist, right? So the algorithms simply
operate in a straightforward way to push,
you know. So whichever side of the
spectrum you're on, it's gonna push you
to the extreme by feeding you algorithms
that are a little bit to the left or a
little bit to the right of where you
currently are. And it does that very
efficiently and creates raving fascists
and raving communists who will then lap
up all of the raving content that
the world can produce. And there's
there's a whole industry, you know, that
has grown up simply to feed that process.
So that simple algorithm—It's not very
smart, it's a reinforcement learning
algorithm—has possibly destroyed the EU
NATO, Western democracy, and that's
just 50 lines of code, right? Imagine
imagine if it was if it was a really
intelligent system operating.